caleb is with us in Columbus Ohio hi
Caleb how are you doing Great Dane
yourself better than I deserve what's up
I am currently in baby step seven and
looking to move up to a more expensive
home we have part of the difference
almost all the difference of the house
saved and just wondering what the Ramsey
approved method would be to do this well
baby step seven meaning your current
home is paid off yes sir okay and your
household income is what arm
depending on the year it's between 80
and 105 right over time Oh
congratulations very well done what's
your current home worth - ah 200 210
cool good for you and how much you're
talking about moving up probably the
next one will be a three hundred 299 310
somewhere in there okay so somewhere
around a hundred grand and how much of
the hundred grand have you got um 60 80
or 90
you're almost there almost well that's
the thing do I wait yeah
it's 20 minutes it's right there within
reach it's not like it's a five-year
issue here
I mean guy yeah you're right there
there's no way I'd go back in debt when
you're that close she who must be obeyed
how to decided we're getting another
house that's the other yeah part of the
equation well okay so that's a different
show that you need to call I've got to
kill me when we play this back yeah
happy wife happy life I know listen I
mean if you were if you were $200,000
off or $100,000 off or something and you
were willing to go back into debt and
you were willing to put that on a very
short-term note I wouldn't yell at you I
wouldn't do it there's no way I'm going
once you get out of that I you couldn't
drag me back into that I mean yes your
life is too good including a she that
must be obeyed she'd have to deal with
me because
I couldn't do it there's no way if
Sharon rimsey wants to do something
right now I'm believe me she's pretty
strong will she wants to do something
but there's no possible freakin way I'm
going into debt it's just not happening
I've gotten out man I'm free but but
other people I mean you might not feel
that strongly and you'd be willing to
take out a little mortgage and pay it
off really really fast but in this case
man you're like ten thousand dollars off
shut up just doing the process of how do
i buy and sell and do it all in one move
that's the other part of it requires one
of two things either it requires two
moves which is the obvious methodology
you sell it moving to a rental and then
buy something or you sell your house or
buy the other house contingent upon the
sale of yours and you put your home on
the market the good news is most real
estate markets are pretty hot right now
and you can go you know write a contract
to buy the other property contingent
upon the sale of yours put yours on the
market instantly and at an aggressive
price and it'll sell pretty fast and
then usually I'm a realtor so it mine
will go in contracting three days okay
then with a bidding war but the one I'm
looking at I got my eye on one and the
guy it's overpriced right now I'm trying
to get him to get a reasonable value but
the thing is going to need 50 grand it
said it's the house is worth 330 it
needs 50 to 70 in upgrades at some point
well then you've got that money need it
needs 10 or it needs 10 or 20 before you
can move that oh then you you got a
problem on where you're going to live
yeah while you're doing this renovation
so you are moving twice to do that I
mean there's this I mean where are you
going to live who's going to buy your
house and let you live there for six
months while you renovate another one
nobody yeah that's a weird brain yeah it
might be you might find somebody
transferring in you know next you know
March or something that wants to go mark
it's hard enough they want to go ahead
and buy it but that that'd be a very
unusual deal
and by the way 330 if it needs 50k in
work
that thing's not worth 280 okay yeah
you're right I got it what what margin
do you put in there for yourself you
gotta you know you got all your time and
screwing with this I'm gonna knock
another 10% off easy minimum okay if I'm
buying it as an investment I'm not going
25% off but you're right you're moving
in it but I mean yeah right area it's
the right house it's just not the right
house but um and you know you're in the
business don't get married to a stupid
house you get married to a stupid house
you're getting rid of pay too much and
you're going to redo a bad deal for you
and your family because you got house
fever go take a cold shower
it's just how similar you know I love
houses but I mean I like doing deals but
don't don't get all caught up keep your
walkaway power emotionally aún mama and
and then y'all decide if this really is
God showing you to buy this house and
what I look at on that from a faith
perspective I'll I stuff has to line up
or I think that's God talking to me if I
can't get it all the line up in other
words I got to get a reasonable price on
this mine's got a cell I got to find a
place to camp while I do this rehab or
drag my possession out as long as I can
on mine the one you're living in if you
can drag the possession out maybe you
can give them a you know some money and
rent it that's to keep from moving for
60 days and jump on that rehab real hard
I don't know you tries all kinds of
stuff but if you the more of that stuff
you get to line up the more I start
calling it a god thing this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show